I came in not knowing but I was really
coming in for I was brought into a room
that had a big mirror in front of me and
they asked us questions about first
impressions I just started talking away
about my imperfections and what parts of
myself I see them I haven't told this to
anyone it's really going over how I
viewed myself and how I think others
view me I've definitely struggled with
weight issues I definitely look at
people and I'm like do I look fat today
cuz my hair like all right you always
want to have better skin have a better
body I'm kind of self-conscious of my
round face especially like my cheekbones
here he's in shape he has nice cheeks he
has really nice cheekbones I feel like
he's the life of the party and I'd
gravitate towards him I think I have
donkey legs that's a great body type I
don't know if she realizes how lucky she
is I never really felt like I was manly
I definitely think that he is like
masculine he seems like a cool guy I've
always been self-conscious of my dimples
I really like her smile she has really
cute dimples she's probably a really fun
person when I look in the mirror I'm
like do I need to lose weight
I think she's in shape if she's mean to
herself then that's just kind of one of
those weird things or everybody's
harsher on themselves
[Music]
oh boy okay I think she's pretty it's
got a great beard she has a great smile
he's like really say something it means
something that was so crazy Wow I wasn't
really expecting that so no one heard
what was going on oh I feel a lot better
now it is cool to see somebody else's
perspective mirror lies man I guess ya
don't trust a mirror like people think
completely different than like what you
might think of yourself we all see
what's bad about our own body we don't
actually see what's great I am stuck in
my body till I die so what good is it
gonna do if I mean to myself you're
better than who you think you are and
that you're enough just the way you are
so be kinder to yourself
[Music]